[Musique]
comment s'appelle l'heureuse élue shao
pierre paul ling hashid abdul mohamed
ben hassen david morris isaac les niches
où tout le monde sourit jean monnet qui
sourit pas bonjour plus ce message était
nouée commencer on va passer noël chez
tes parents
on évite tous les sujets qui fâchent
israël dalaï lama la burqa tu devras
jackie chan arafat il aura kadhafi
noriko macias qui pâturent à bruce lee
et popeck un mot sur l'équipe de france
de foot
et si quelqu'un balance a penché sur les
juifs tu laisse couler si quelqu'un fait
l'amalgamé entre immigration et
délinquance
toi tu dis rien et si on a un qui
balance une bonne sur les chinois je
fais pas tu souris hp chinois quoi en
fait
suce boules en chef
je pensais à votre petite dernière il se
mariera peut-être avec un catholique
je vais me marier et les catholiques oui
on se réjouit des minutes de retard on
est au moins sûr de jeu c'est pas à
chênois
ces ateliers se présente charles iii
[ __ ] plus un noir porté par an se
font mouche ima les français sont vos
mauvais effet
si j'en parle moindre propos racistes à
l'égard mémoire aa je n'ai pas à son
poste à 400 et il veut rien payé amin
dada tu peux être cool pour une fois tu
m'as pris pour l'anglo benz va nous
faire le splendide métis qu'est ce que
la chaise-dieu cloud dans le noir
[Musique]